good morning everybody and welcome to
first vice-president
timmermans and vice-president Katainen
thank with us for this press conference
presenting the Commission action to step
up
EU action to protect and restore the
world's forests you will have able to
find online also the press release a
memo and effect [ __ ] we just adopted and
stepping up EU action to protect the
restore the world's forests forests host
80% of biodiversity on land support the
livelihoods of around a quarter of the
world's population and are vital to
efforts to fight climate change
protecting forests is a significant part
of our responsibility to meet the
commitments under the Paris agreement
because greenhouse gas emissions linked
to deforestation are the second biggest
cause of climate change the figures are
quite shocking between 1990 and 2016 the
world has been losing forest cover at a
rate equivalent to about 800 football
pitches an hour and while the EU is not
home to the major primary forests of the
world our consumption habits have a
significant impact on them the EU
represents around 10 percent of final
consumption of products associated with
deforestation the EU has consistently
taken action to tackle deforestation
forest degradation we're not starting
from scratch but it's time to step up
our efforts to improve people's health
and livelihoods and ensure a healthy
planet for our children and
grandchildren at this stage in the
institutional cycle of course it's not
appropriate for us to come out with new
ledge
station but we will continue until the
31st of October to do all the necessary
work so that the incoming Commission can
hit the ground running and so no time is
wasted rules life on the line presented
her climate ambitions in the European
Parliament last week and I could well
imagine the tackling deforestation would
feature in the European Green Deal that
she plans to present in our first 100
days in office as well as in the next
Commission's biodiversity strategy farm
to fork strategy on sustainable food
policies and in the sustainable Europe
investment plan the objectives of
today's communication are twofold
firstly and most importantly we need to
protect the existing forest cover
especially the primary forests which are
a most important carbon store and host
the greatest biodiversity on the planet
secondly as a complementary measure and
not as an alternative we need to find
ways and means to sustainably regenerate
and increase forest cover the EU cannot
do this alone we need to be part of a
global alliance that is why our
communication propose a partnership
approach we need all players on board
producer and consumer countries and
international organizations as well as
businesses civil societies the
scientific community and all of us as
individual consumers and citizens we are
setting out today a number of tools that
can be put into practice immediately and
we're launching preparatory work for
possible regulatory measures which can
be easily picked up and built upon by
the incoming Commission our
communication is built around five
priorities your key will elaborates in a
minute on the proposed work with partner
countries and international cooperation
which you could call the supply side on
the more domestic side or the demand
side we need to focus on reducing he use
consumption footprint we must make sure
that the products we consume come from
deforestation free supply chains we will
quickly launch a new multi-stakeholder
platform on deforestation and forest
degradation to help deliver on this goal
we will also look at the standards and
certification schemes that promote
deforestation free products
and develop relevant guidance and we
will start assessing new regulatory
measures to prevent EU consumption
linked to deforestation and forest
degradation another pillar of our
proposal is is financial we have to
redirect public and private finance to
more sustainable land use and to protect
protection and regeneration of forests
lastly we need to keep up research and
innovation to provide more better
quality information on forest products
and supply change chains this includes
establishing an EU observatory on
deforestation and forest degradation to
monitor changes in the world's forests
cover the resource will give public
bodies consumers and businesses better
access to relevant information so that
it can make better informed decisions
the Commission will also explore the
possibility of strengthening the use of
copernicus satellite system for forest
monitoring as you can see there's a lot
of work to come in the next five years
and I've only told you half of it so let
me hand over now to Yuki to tell you
what else we have set out in our
communication to do Yuki thank you very
much good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
France already provided a big all you on
why we are here today announced in this
particular communication the issue of
disappearance of global forest cover is
a very complex issue
as forests are linked to create variety
of issues such as people's livelihood
biodiversity carbon sequestration water
quality and so on lately deforestation
has not been an issue in your way we
have by activity and awareness actually
reversed the trend and being able to
increase our forest cover but globally
diverse station remains a serious issue
especially in the tropics although this
is not an issue in Europe we are not
detached from the problem as France
mentioned we are linked to it for we are
for example we are our consumption and
trade it is good to remember that this
is not the first time the Commission has
taken action on deforestation for
example we
worked we are our so-called select
program development policy trade agenda
and our previous deforestation strategy
from 2000-2008 although much has been
done it's evident that the problem is
still far from being solved that is why
we are here today to step up our action
on two main fronts to hold deforestation
and increase the world's forests cover
protecting the world's forests and
increasing the first cover are
complementing actions by preserving
natural forests and planting new ones
are we are saving biodiversity and
decreasing the pressure on our sources
sounds simple but unfortunately there is
no quick and simple fix to this highly
cross-cutting issue otherwise it would
have been it would have already been
solved
due to the complexity we are here in the
Commission have worked together with
several colleagues in order to currenty
a much-needed horizontal approach from
trade to development cooperation and
also date but it is not enough that we
are here in the commission to take
action in Finland one of our main many
forests related phrases says roughly
translated that the forest will echo
what you saw to it so as we are
reinforcing our action I would like to
highlight the importance of good
cooperation with the prospective third
countries several of the deforestation
related issues have links to complex
socio-economic issues like poverty
population growth and caps in covenants
only with credible long-term action we
can create a sustainable change to halt
deforestation and increase the global
forest cover these why in our
communication we are underlining the
partnership approach and taking broad
action to bring our partnership
countries on port for example we are to
pay attention that our development
cooperation does not cause deforestation
and we will
say our best practices were the
countries when Roland this includes
helping partner countries to develop
national frameworks on forests as well
as creating incentive mechanisms for
smallholder farmers who are crucial for
sustainable land management and also we
will see that our trade policy supports
our messages this means among other
things that we will continue ensuring
that trade agreements collated by the
you contribute to the responsible and
sustainable management of the global
supply chains as France mentioned the
next commission will most likely
continue the work on this these topics
and the communication is a clear signal
from our side that we are taking our
responsibility seriously and also taking
concrete access thank you very much
questions
Sarika my question is for vice-president
amendments I would like to ask in what
way does this communication advance the
Commission's position from the study
done and published in February last year
on ways to address the first station
because in that one you already outlined
options and in the communication from
what I can read now it seems they are
also outlining options secondly I wanted
to ask when you talk about incentives to
trade partners to address the forest
station what concrete measures are you
talking about and finally a Mercosur
specifically under which precise
conditions will the Commission proposed
measures that could allow member states
to block Mercosur imports if they have
evidence showing that these were linked
with the first station thank you on the
first question what we're doing now is
setting the scene for what could be done
by the next Commission in terms of
concrete legislative proposals so we're
framing the debate in the direction in
which
we believe it should go what we're also
proposing is some concrete measures such
as to create high level platforms so
that information can be exchanged and
everybody involved in the issue can be
part of that we had very good experience
in the area of sustainability with such
a platform and it really helped us
advance on the issue of sustainability
and I'm sure will also help us advance
on this issue and thirdly I also want to
mention the observatory which is going
to be a place where information can be
gathered and sort out by countries when
they have a problem with deforestation
and this information can help this
observatory can give them the
information to take better informed
decisions I think this is a very useful
tool especially if you can also use the
results of remote sensing of satellite
observation and all of that and feed
that into that Observatory that you get
really concentration of knowledge that
would help Member States and others to
take informed decisions because before I
give the floor to yogi one of the
crucial elements here is that it's a
global issue being pattern izing to the
rest of the world is certainly not going
to work anymore so we need to make sure
we offer cooperation and this is what
we're trying to do and that's actually
at the core of our communication
thinking yeah thank you very on creating
incentives for trade partners it means
all the countries who are trading with
us also including those with whom we
have already made a trade agreement so I
just give you a couple of concrete
examples as the communication indicates
we are willing to assess the possibility
to create standards and certification
schemes that promote deforestation
products so this would be a big thing if
we manage to create standards and
certification schemes it would
immediately have a trade impact to know
you can create impact to the trade and
and those who want to sell products to
our market
should follow our standard also we want
to assess additional regulatory and non
regulatory measures to minimize the EU
consumption linked to deforestation also
awareness-raising especially when it
comes to the value chains is very
important
third question or third element I want
to mention is our work on sustainable
finance as you probably know we have
issues or we have proposed a new
sustainable finest proposal it which is
on the table of the council currently
and the European Parliament and this
again would have a significant impact to
sustainability because immediately once
financial market starts following new
stainability criteria it will have a big
impact to the investments and the
overall business financing also we want
to explore protect company reporting on
impacts of activities on deforestation
and forest degradation so so those all
four points I raised are just examples
what can sent ifs we can do so you have
to understand incentive in a in a sense
that we want to change the way to market
operates and precondition for this is to
get better data we have to know what is
the reality and it's the basis for
creating new tools then on Marrakesh or
I am very well aware that there are many
people saying that we should not have a
Mercosur trade a cream of the year
because of deforestation impact so we
all know that there's been serious
issues in in Mercosur country especially
in Brussels when it comes to to rain
forest degradation so this is an issue
in which we don't want to make any
compromises whatsoever
as France already said the deforestation
is a significant problem and there are
from 2000 from 1990 till 2016 800
football fields have been or equivalent
to 800 foot home fields per hour have
been have been lost in terms of forest
coverage and and this is an issue which
we don't want to jeopardize anymore
but when you look at the Mercosur trade
agreement we have very strong robust
sustainable development chapter pate in
it and it gives a stronger hand to us to
have a political dialogue with Brussels
but also with the other American
countries on sustainable sustainability
related issues it has been mentioned
explicitly that increasing trade cannot
lead increasing deforestation and if
this was the case then if Mercosur trade
agreements been accepted we would have a
better say stronger say on these issues
so all this deforestation has happened
without trade equipment but now we have
created with Mercosur countries that as
a precondition of Trade Agreement trade
at the same time when it's supposed to
be increasing must be more sustainable
so basically all of us must choose
whether we have we want a stronger
negotiating role with a V Merkers
countries or then we just follow by
watching what is the development and
it's always better to be in a stronger
position so the agreement also includes
a binding commitment to implement Paris
agreement which all Mercosur countries
are signature parties and process
nationally determined contributions
under the Paris agreement includes the
following pledges to be achieved by 2030
first zero illegal deforestation in
Brazilian Amazon
and conversation for greenhouse gas
emissions also restoring reforesting 12
million hectares of forest for multiple
purposes and and many others so those
are the issue which we are following
very very strongly and now we have a
political means to to look after them
she would even to do miss hitting
romance is usually passkey Musa Pokemon
Kia play didn't you say your hotel
traduction Magisto escutcheon complete
comment on the von der Leyen a pursuit
in your supply description at the
location damn periodical escrow see NPC
to see you loo look every summer heat
Hawaii then I push English is like your
niece it increments setting this isn't a
commission OPN aqua wasn't a commission
like punk or DC didn't rat on us a
decision
Parvati screws referred on a portion
Commission does emo anatra v2s canoes
Ivanka's auntie Audrey a complete Monica
of X occur also from the line I declare
a parliament open ask LEDs you say
premier sunroofs karate so the Green
Deal which is an expression Frances dr.
Java anakov come play an equivalent
memory action with the presentation
communications on week play the job
prepare a high position some soup ask
assume welfare to Southern Sun would be
amplify all the way filmmakers from
feature story news mr. Timmons you have
called Boris Johnson he said that he
thought he wasn't being genuinely
thought he's playing games in 25 minutes
is the real prospect there's a real
prospect that he's going to become the
next
Prime Minister do you still stand by
those comments will you welcome him here
with open arms or do you still think
he's playing games well I would just
suggest you look at - what that's what
he's been writing over the years he took
a long time deciding whether he was for
or against brexit and now his position
is clear I think the position of the EU
is also clear the United Kingdom reached
agreement with the European Union and
the European Union will stick to that
agreement and we will hear what the new
Prime Minister has to say when he comes
to Brussels but I think telling any
secrets when I'm saying that Boris
Johnson took his time to decide whether
he was on one side or the other side of
the argument he did that publicly and in
that post presidency the questions for
the vice president amendments I
disappointed a little bit that your
candidacy was blocked by some countries
during the Europeans I mean - can your
candidacy for the President of the
European Commission thank you
well I can't say I'm overjoyed of course
it's disappointing if you're not elected
as president of the European Commission
but countries make up their minds you
know what they think is in their
interest and that's the position they
take and then other countries have to
decide whether they will follow that
reasoning or not and especially a number
of EPP led countries decided to follow
the reasoning that was put on the table
by the prime ministers of Poland and
Hungary that's their decision so it goes
in politics as you know
[Music]
intervention
Mousavi Missoni tutta la cañada station
portable interior Priyanka equilibria
net the consumer sector premiere Moe
Cason le jeu de que el voto por varios a
deciduous concept IBM capacity
complications or problems deforestation
chopped avocado Mazzoni sovereignty
local African sow and a multinational
Europeana eskimo present on the loopy
action is he human on a commission on
freon said a decision keeper vitro
procedure Don sobre sivaraman Kalevala a
kerala LaFave stove or decision coupon
and fluency provide stability
sadistically / su canoes of home sitting
cooperation a Victorian Terrace a Pascal
qua unique no don't at array the
consummate of a pianist we say Donatella
community model that receives a problem
catawampus own the deforestation eco
zepa illumination de lisle Agricole a
don't see TV no on a brand new real
Raimondo we food rate of a desolation
post la pimienta
alla deforestation ceases convey fair a
cooperation of a clip is Africa Lu
Brazil a ultra Paley you come home yank
on the peds may say not go for a office
convo we come from Mission
resin apart on the center head - Lisa -
mm Donna P concerning Oaxaca memorable a
conclusion Cola deforestation set
defeat enormous pool luma Dante D'Amico
pronto par example an anticodon o de
santa casa su padre guru saj day
I tip wood we saw Zeff a pool a
difference a day job in Poncho's leaking
from atop of the jello the decision and
for me c'est pas de Jesus ed I am
pleased on the right I believe in
corporal Susie from this you deserve
Estes model ap yeah pull a de l'épée the
develop in agriculture in a pure booze
one the coop it is up or a the the tree
the for heavier so don't oh not the
mumbles one as we cannot extend our
logistic power to all countries beyond
the European Porter's we we still can
use our our power regulate in the market
so I give you an example of the existing
situation we have for instance limited
the use of pesticides which according
our scientific evidence is harmful for
human human health and this has changed
the market there is no market in Europe
for the products which has been produced
or food product which has been produced
by using banned pesticides for instance
so we change the logic of the market so
we can use the same logic also in other
other areas and that's why I mentioned
earlier that we are assessing standards
and certification schemes that promote
deforestation free products also we are
assessing additional regulatory and non
regulatory measures to minimize you
consumption linked to deforestation so
basically this is a powerful tool
because it will change the logic of the
market and there is no market in Europe
for a sustainable products in the year
in the future once we get all this stuff
done thank you
but try another wallah limo party you
know Turkish president moment CC uh
Libya cerveza de la comisión de
Pompadour lion may look politic snd
don't have a television Candida Oscar
certain delegation not he'll come from
an invader lion not important or true
Pascal was a bit about he directs his
honor Commission hello askew Windows XP
c'mon survivor drop position politic
s-curve a casually on impacted the
Vltava me give you that new new disc
ever taken from alum von der Leyen
Eve at her utility Cosimo LA
Commissioner please not the lyrical was
a little come over here said situation
[Music]
for me salute wash a car not a of the
Polynesian Sula the Zemo Libya Libya
Scottie madam from the line silly
political vermin aorta present a
commission OPN
a bow kudos a politic take a laser xpk
opera opera ovn de como de programa de
partido socialista opium don't depend
view de programa que la disputa a
copolymer OPA is a bazooka alight a loop
so there's a remote repository my famiiy
politic don't you say cantando pouvoir
municipality come up with a commission
from the line
Sally Party uncovered what the decision
sir the portfolio Arabia cadmium me -
quaaaack jhol scale I speak ill of
Parliament as Mandela a different view
the continuity politique the sunday
shows key command vonda idea exhume the
kunikida not a platform a socialist
Paula company electoral a remember mark
a certain delegation asada ma famille
politic the vote count madam from the
line Pascal for the reason the
Franciscans sutanu the system which fits
in candidate measurement on salary scale
ADIZ or the program Calvo applicant le
président the Commission open
se set attitude positive the lava mr.
Solis Kyra's parent received not have I
flew to a positive don't is any question
for vice president two moments Jonathan
Rugman from channel 4
Boris Johnson recently put the chances
of a No Deal brexit at a million to one
what do you think the chances are
gambling man and and we'll have to wait
for what the new Prime Minister assuming
it's Boris Johnson will have to say
about that
as far as the Commission is concerned I
think we negotiated in good faith I
think what came out of the negotiation
is the best possible solution in a very
complicated situation it does justice to
the position of both the EU and the
United Kingdom and I would hope we could
continue to work on the basis of that
Lucian and I I think if you have an
agreement between a country and an
organization like the EU I think it it's
the responsibility of all to to stick to
that agreement and make it work I think
you know I think a No Deal breaks it a
hard break it would be a tragedy for all
sides not just for the United Kingdom
I'm not one of those are saying oh god
they're going to suffer if we're all
going to suffer that happens and I think
you know if I look back at the last
years I don't think there were many
people in United Kingdom when they voted
for brexit that intentionally voted for
a No Deal brexit I don't think that
happened I think there is a strong
willingness in British society to come
out of this in a reasonable way and I
think the best way to come out of this
is on the basis of the agreement that
was reached with the European Union
thanks a lot Alex pigmen from national
supplies just as a follow-up to that
Boris Johnson is a very colorful
character he's someone who sometimes
runs fast with the truth I that's a very
different chief negotiator if you will
than Theresa May are you worried about
this this sort of bombastic figure who's
now going to be in front of you is it
does the European Union require a new
strategy to face this this this new I
dare say opponent well the world's
politics is rife of colorful people
these days so if you can't deal with
them there's not much you could do my
advice would be just to you know to
stick to your position and and have a
reasonable attitude and stick stick
clearly to the position that this is the
best deal possible and I think this is
the approach the European leaders will
have and you know with my experience
whenever there is a new prime minister
in any member state or country he or she
will be welcomed as a colleague by their
colleagues and they'll try and sort it
out
but again and I don't think his
character or persona or attitude makes
any difference in that sense and I
honestly believe and I can't say this
enough that we reached a deal that is in
my view the best possible deal and I
hope this is something that is
understood in Westminster and this is
the way we should move forward thanks
David hers done with with Politico vice
president Ramirez just to come back to
your question to follow up startup to
jump around a bit I mean I'm sure it
must be very flattering to see a lot of
your campaign platform adopted almost
verbatim by the president-elect at the
same time obviously that can create some
tension to have a potential vice
president who is as eminently qualified
your name obviously being debated by the
European Council before hers before the
presidency someone who has much more
experience here in the Belmont in the
Commission do you worry that that can
create some tension should mrs. von der
Leyen feel a little bit threatened by is
is that maybe why you don't know what
your portfolio will be yet that there's
some uncomfortability potentially there
despite the agreement on the views it
seems almost natural from a human
perspective that it's hard to have
someone next to you who was essentially
first in line for that job you know if I
look back at my own career and and just
just asked jean-claude Juncker or asked
Margaret or young BAE to bulk and or
other people I've worked with I'm an
independent thinker have always been
that of it I'm very much my own person
but in in politics I'm also very loyal
I'm loyal to the system because I
believe in the system it needs to be
reformed but I'm still loyal to the
system and I'm loyal to prime ministers
and presidents if I work with them and
that's been my attitude throughout my
political career and that's not going to
change and I hope I can put what I know
my experience at the service of European
citizens you know we're not at the
service of individuals with the service
of other citizens and that's been what's
been driving me for the last 30 years
and that's not
to change last questions David thank you
David price your democracy it's a follow
up on your last reply about independence
and loyalty to party the institutions
going through a major crisis of which
brexit is a centum and the part of that
is the dissonance between what's
happening in the Commission which is
it's become very party political and the
treaties themselves say that the
commissioners should be composed of
people whose independence is beyond
doubt and if you are loyal to a party
then you following a party ideology
which means your independence is not
beyond ours as far as the general public
is concerned and I'm wondering whether
before the oath of office which will
affirm your independence as a
commissioner you will resign from the
Socialist Party to reaffirm research
your independence I have to say in all
honesty David during the last five years
repeatedly when you've asked me a
question I had to think of it before
answering again today
perhaps I didn't I wasn't clear enough
in my previous answer I'm loyal to an
idea of Europe I'm loyal to the persons
I have to work with and I'm a member of
a political party and I will remain a
member of the political party just as
much as any member of the Commission is
a member of a political party and part
of a political system I don't really see
the problem of that I think had the
younger Commission not been a political
commission we would never have been able
to achieve the results we've achieved
had we not been a political commission
we would never have had the support of
the middle of the majority of the
European Parliament in some of the most
far-reaching decisions any commission
has ever taken in the last five years so
you can't take politics out of the
you can't take politics out of politics
we are a political organization this was
intended to be like that
initially the commission of course was
an institution created in a completely
different world in in a world where
politics was still completely in the
hands of paternalism when politicians
would go out and say well I knew you
don't understand current citizens but
trust me I'll do what's right for you
that world's gone we need to be
accountable on a daily basis for
everything we do and that's highly
political and every single member of the
European Commission the present and the
next Commission will have her or his
links with a political movement or party
that's that's the world we live in and I
think that's only right that's only the
only way you can move forward in a very
political world and you know I would I
would use one argument against your
pessimism the pessimism you expressed at
the beginning we've seen in the European
elections an increase in participation
of European citizens across the board so
this political Europe is attracting
step-by-step more attention by European
citizens we've also seen and I can
testify to that in my own campaign and
increasing understanding with European
citizens that they need the European
Union to solve some of the problems that
can no longer be solved only on a
national basis so I'm more optimistic
than you are David and I believe we can
really move forward in this area in the
next five years and of course being at a
political you know when you saw the way
the European Council operated its highly
political it was no longer just about
nationalities it was also about
political families it was also about the
political balances you need as a
reflection of what the political
realities in the Member States are so
I'm not at all pessimistic about that I
think this is the right way forward and
of course it's not going to be an easy
going of course it's going to be
difficult but the world is a difficult
place we have huge challenges life
rending challenges so let's face them I
say was president of EPP party I could
say couple of words on this issue to say
especially the European parties are not
monoliths they are usually divided from
within
and there's everybody knows so it's not
a straitjacket that you you should or
one should be loyal to party in a sense
because I'm someone may remember was the
case in the Soviet era so it's much more
different thing today and as France said
it would be sad to pretend not to be
part of the political life because we
all have a political background and we
still believe that party politics part
of the living democracy part of our
civil society functioning in in that
sense I was relieved when jean-claude
Juncker announced that this commission
is going to be political so basically my
interpretation of being political
committees in commission follows two
principles first there's no point to
pretend that commission is like a is a
body which lives in value vacuums we are
regulators we do European board
regulations and regulations always are
pasted on our lives and values so we
choose over the other options that I
want to go to this direction for
instance on a circular economy or
deforestation because my value says this
is right direction and when we do think
things like that we choose out and other
options so Commission is always of
political but then when it comes to the
implementation or or being cloudy of the
traded air the Commission cannot be
political because we have a duty based
on treaties that we are the cutting of
the treaty we must treat everybody the
same way so we need to to create justice
or make sure that justice happens in
Europe so so being political doesn't
mean that independence of the
institution is jeopardized but but it's
a it's this thinking is based on this
division being the cutting of the
treaties after we have
created a legislation but before we must
be political eventually first vice
president and vice president who brought
us on a wider political character then
they already wide the domain of forests
and so thank you and there will be the
midday briefing pretty soon in a few
minutes so stay tuned I hope you have a
great summer and a bit of rest
Parkside ballroom I wish you